you are definitely gonna need some
context for this one so my friend hazel
she was in my film she's currently
editing her own film which I am in
playing a zombie she's asked me to
record some extra zombie noises for her
to put into the film and this is what I
am going to send her thank you for
purchasing Charlie's miscellaneous
zombie noises please pick the noise
appropriate based on the zombies emotion
basic growl happy sad angry scared
tender sympathetic angsty eating aroused
sleeping
laughing depressed supportive friend
looking for scissors no a brief moment
of peace
videoblogging thank you once again for
purchasing Charlie's miscellaneous
zombie noises say goodbye zombie you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool okay here's last
week's video in case you missed it also
here's hazel who you should definitely
check out her film super brand new
zombies comes out at some point this
month of course you also have the option
here of watching any other video that
you want to on YouTube but it's my
humble opinion that one of these two
videos is your best possible choice
right now definitely undoubtedly one of
these two out of the millions pick one
and your life will be so much better
thank you goodbye
depressed I did about there